from em uh he Scheck Anand I hope I
pronounced that okay does the idea
really matter or the way you market it
hey that's a great question um I think
the idea matters but more importantly
it's kind of the relentless execution
started with what is the value
proposition and then go to market with
it and again with the digital age you
can get stuff out there in weeks they
used to take years a good example where
actually the the shift in terms of
market and I do you probably saw the
film joy jailer law and with joy Mangano
in terms of what happened there was what
was a mock company I used her life
savings actually 70 percent of our
customers used their life savings to
fund their businesses but there was a
pivotal moment when it just was not
moving I don't know it was like on QVC
where we just couldn't get any sales
away and she she was gonna get dropped
as a product on that channel and she
persuaded them to give her the
opportunity to pitch her own product and
like within the next 20 minutes they
sold 18,000 mops so just a product
matter the idea it was a great idea
but the sales and marketing was awesome
and and you know you can market your
product better than anybody else and the
Internet is a channel and YouTube and
you know vines gives you a unique
opportunity to market your product
hopefully so that lady after 10 years
and sold 200 million dollars worth of
moths and you probably wouldn't think
there's a lot of innovation in the world
of mops but boy oh boy a hat tip and a
salute to joy it's a lot of marks yeah
you know for me this is it's both right
you need the idea and you need the
marketing if you were marketing a bad
idea it's not gonna take off right
especially in this area where
word-of-mouth is so fast and people can
talk about how bad your product is the
best market in the world won't save a
terrible product the idea is also
important because if you have crappy
marketing then it's not going to take
off either so you need both I think also
just even talk with the execution the
the creation of the product because a
lot of people have an idea but they
don't actually then create that product
or create that service and just sits
there then well one day I'm gonna do
this one day I'm gonna start and then
never actually start and so the
execution of actually creating the prior
to creating the service and then marking
it is both right it's not just one or
the other you need to have both if
you're gonna have success as
entrepreneur yeah it interests me on a
you know in terms of today I don't think
it's just where you have the idea but
I'd say now if you've got first mover
advantage you can create a marketplace
sometimes maybe 10-15 years ago if you
had first movement Vantage you'd find
your idea was too early for the
marketplace and then one of the big guys
would steal the idea and scale up and
you'd sit there thinking I had that idea
and they build a business out of that
today I think through the digital age
you can get an idea to market really
quickly and you can scale it up evolve
it improve it and build a really
scalable successful business